Prof: So back to
business.
We're in a really great
position here because we've gone
from one dimension to three
dimensions, to get something
real, a real atom.
And if you take that table from
last time,
that we got from the old-time
mathematicians,
and plug in according to what
you can use together,
you get the exact wave function
that's a solution of the
Schrödinger equation for
the hydrogen atom,
or any atom that has only one
electron.
It can have any nuclear charge
you want, right?
So it's the real thing.
People have shown you pictures,
which are some kinds of
approximations of this,
but you have the equation,
the actual formula,
for the true wave function,
and no one has a better one
than you have.
That's the real McCoy.
Okay?
And you can check these
pictures that people have drawn
to see if they're realistic
graphs,
or whether they're just some
kind of artist's impression,
or somebody who doesn't know
anything's impression;
maybe he's not even an artist.
Right?
So you can actually do these.
And many of them are very
simple functions,
like e^(-r),
right?
You can hardly get easier than
that.
Okay, but you can also draw
pictures that look just like
what you could see if the
electron had a color to it.
They're done by ray tracing
where the computer pretends it's
your eye and sees how much
density it would go through,
if it went through this point
or that point or that point,
along a certain ray from your
eye, and puts a color here
that's proportional to how much
electron density it sees.
It's not the wave function;
it's the square of the wave
function, the electron density,
that Atom-in-a-Box
plots.
Okay?
So that's what it would really
look like,
if you could see it and if
there weren't problems with
wavelength and photons knocking
electrons to kingdom come and so
on.
That's what it would look like,
right?
But it'll be colored;
it'll be colored according to
the sign the wave function has.
It's not the wave function;
it's the square of the wave
function.
So it would be positive.
But it's colored to say the
wave function in this region
would be positive or in this
region negative.
And I'll show it to you in just
a second, but first let's -- or
a few minutes -- but first let's
describe it.
So there's lots of information
on the screen that you get with
Atom-in-a-Box.
How many of you have tried it?
Okay, all of you should.
Okay?
Okay, first you have the
Schrödinger equation.
That always appears and it's
sort of silly but if you need
the Schrödinger equation
for reference,
there it is.
Then up at the top is the
particular function that's being
plotted,
and it's given as n,
l and m,
and also the nickname
1s, for this particular
one,
which is 1,0,0 for n,
l and m.
And then there's the formula
that that particular wave
function has,
and you know what it is,
it's a bunch of constants,
which we can forget,
but it's e^(-r).
He's not using Ï
here, notice.
He uses actual r and
puts in explicitly the Z
and the a_o,
and the two is cancelled.
Okay?
And then he says what the
energy would be,
in units of electron volts.
An electron volt is 23.06 times
as big as a kilocalorie,
which is what we usually talk
in.
Now, you can look at these
pictures and ask questions,
some fairly simple questions,
like where is the electron
density highest?
The nucleus is in the center of
this picture,
not surprisingly.
So this is not a hard question.
Where's the electron density
highest?
Prof: In the middle,
right?
No big surprise there.
Okay, how do you know?
You take the wave function,
you square it and find out
where it has a maximum,
and e^(-distance) has a
maximum when the distance is
zero;
the value is one.
It falls off from there.
Okay, so you just,
to find where the density is
highest, you just square the
wave function and maximize it.
Okay, now but here's a slightly
different question:
What is the most likely
distance?
Can you see why that's a
different question than where --
you might think the most likely
distance is wherever the density
is highest,
but that's not quite true.
Do you see why?
Student:
>
Prof: Because what's
most-- yes?
Student:  It could be
moving very quickly in the area.
Prof: No,
it doesn't have to do with
motion.
Yes Lucas?
Student:  There's almost
no volume in the center.
Prof: There's almost no
volume in the center.
If you take--say if you talk
about a point,
then there's no volume at all.
Okay?
But take a little box and put
it in the center,
or actually a sphere of a
certain radius,
a small radius,
0.0001 Å
say,
and put it in the center,
and see how much density is
inside.
Okay?
But then you could look at one
angstrom out,
and now you're looking at a
little spherical shell that's
0.0001 Å
thick.
Is everybody clear?
So there could be different
directions in which you have
this electron density,
which is at that particular
distance from the nucleus.
And the further out you go,
the more volume this shell has.
It's always the same thickness,
but as you move out there's
more stuff in it.
You see what I mean?
More volume in it.
What's it proportional to?
As you increase r,
how does the volume of the
shell increase?
How does the surface of the
sphere increase as you go out?
Student:  r^(3).
Prof: No,
volume is r^(3).
Student:  r^(2).
Prof: It goes with
r^(2).
The surface goes with
Right?
So you have to multiply the
probability density by
r^(2),
to see at what radius you have
the most stuff.
Is that clear to everyone?
Because you want to count
everything that's at that
radius,
not only in that direction but
also in that direction,
that direction,
and so on,
and the sphere gets bigger as
you go out.
So you'll notice that what's
given in this plot here on the
bottom right is r^(2)
times the wave function squared.
Okay?
So that'll tell you what's the
most likely distance.
Okay?
So you have to do surface
weighting by r^(2),
and it's not at zero,
it's at the unit that we use to
measure distance in,
a_0, which turns out to
be half an angstrom,
0.53 Å.
Okay, now here's a 2s
orbital.
Right?
Here we'll draw two different
shells of the same thickness,
right?
We'll number them one and two,
and we're going to ask the
question, which one has higher
density?
<<Technical adjustments
of room lighting>>
Okay, which shell has higher
density, one or two?
Student:  One.
Prof: One, clearly, okay?
Now, here's a different
question -- okay,
it shows one -- which shell
contains more electron density,
more stuff?
Which one has more probability?
Students:  Two.
Prof: It's not obvious,
because one has higher density
but two is much bigger.
Okay?
And in fact,
the two has about three times
the radius of one.
Right?
So how much more volume does
that shell have?
Student:  Nine times.
Prof: About nine times
more volume;
not of the sphere but of the
shell.
Okay?
So it's about nine times the
volume.
So it turns out that actually
two has more stuff,
and you see that in this plot.
Right?
The red for two is bigger than
the green for one.
Right?
So depending on what question
you ask, you have to decide
whether you have to weight it by
r^(2) to get the answer
you need.
Okay, now here's another way of
looking at a wave function.
This happens to be the -- it's
actually a 3D wave function;
as you see, not from here,
but from here,
it's 3D.
This is the picture in three
dimensions, using that ray
tracing, the way we talk about.
But you can do it,
if you click "Slice"
down here, then you get a slice
through it.
Okay?
So that's 2-dimensional,
more like the contour plots
we've been using.
It's just a slice through the
3D thing.
So this is a 2D,
not a projection,
but an actual slice of it,
and with this slider here you
can control where the slice is.
It's in the middle there;
so it goes through the nucleus.
But if you want,
you can slide it down and see
what the slice would be if it
were in front of the screen that
you sliced this picture.
Everybody got it?
So you can look at different
levels that way,
if you want to,
or you can pretend you're
looking at the whole thing.
So it can be near or far.
Okay, now let's look at these
two different,
the 2D and the 3D pictures,
and look at the pattern of
nodes,
the shape and the energy of the
3d orbital.
You see here that there are
diagonal nodes in this 3d
orbital.
Okay?
So that's 3d.
Let's look at this one.
Now we still have those two
diagonal nodes.
In fact, it turns out that the
nodes are actually cones.
This is a slice through a cone,
on the top, and on the bottom.
Okay?
So the nodal surface -- bear in
mind that in one dimension a
node is a point;
in two dimensions a node is a
line;
in three dimensions a node is a
surface.
Right?
So we're slicing it and see an
intersection of the conical
surface here,
but the actual node is a cone.
Okay, but is that the only node
that you see in that picture on
the right?
Student:  There's a
circular--
Prof: Ah-ha,
Angela says she sees a circle
too.
Right?
So there are two kinds of nodes
in this orbital.
There's both a conical node,
which we had in the previous
one;
the 3d orbital had a
conical node.
That's what makes it a d
orbital, having a conical node.
But this one also has a
spherical node,
which is a circle when we slice
it.
Okay?
So is this higher energy or
lower energy than the one we
looked at before?
Students:  Higher.
Prof: How do you know
it's higher?
Student:  Nodes.
Student:  More nodes.
Prof: It has more nodes.
Did you ever see a situation
before where you can have two
different kinds of nodes?
Here you have both,
in this section,
both a circle and lines.
You ever see anything like that
before?
Student:  Chladni plates.
Prof: Right.
Anyhow it's higher energy,
it's 4d,
not 3d,
as you said,
and it's like this,
right?
You have both circular and
diameter nodes,
but this is three-dimensional
so you have both sphere and
cone.
So can you guess what a
5d orbital would look
like?
We looked at a 3d
orbital.
This is a 4d orbital.
How about a 5d orbital?
Lucas?
Student:  It would have
a third layer of nodes.
Prof: Not a third layer
of nodes.
It would have how many more
nodes?
Student:  One.
Prof: One more node.
Student:  A circle,
a sphere.
Prof: And it would be --
in the section it would be
another circle;
or actually it's another sphere
of a different diameter.
Okay?
So you see how you can combine
cones in this case--or it can be
planes too;
you have planes for p
orbitals--
you can combine spheres with
planes,
or cones, and you can combine
them in different ways to get
the same energy.
For example,
you can have a sphere and a
cone that has a certain energy--
that's 4d,
the one we're looking at here--
or you could have two sets of
-- forget the sphere but have
another cone.
Does that remind you of
anything?
And get the same energy.
Or you can have a plane and a
cone,
or you could have a sphere and
a plane,
or you can have a sphere and a
cone --
I said that already -- or you
could have two spheres,
or you could have two planes.
All those are two nodes--does
everybody see what I'm
saying--and they all have the
same energy.
Does that remind you of
anything?
It's not exactly the same,
but it should remind you of
something.
That's what Chladni saw;
remember, you could get
different combinations,
in his case,
of circles and lines,
and get the same frequency.
Right?
So that's why the 2s and
the 2p have the same
energy, or the 3s,
the 3p and 3d
have the same energy.
Okay, now let's talk about
scaling -- H-like.
What do we mean by H-like?
Student:  One electron.
Prof: It's one electron;
any nuclear charge,
but one electron.
Why incidentally do we want it
to be one electron?
Zack?
Student:  Repulsion.
Prof: That will turn out
to be the case,
but even if that weren't the
case, there's a good reason to
start with one electron.
Yeah?
Student:  You get a
Coulombic interaction between
the electrons.
Prof: Yeah,
it's true that we don't want --
well we'll get into big trouble
when we get Coulomb interaction
between electrons.
It's absolutely right.
But we want to walk before we
try to run;
work with three variables,
not six variables,
which you'd have with two
electrons, or 3n if you
had n electrons.
Right?
So we want simple functions at
the beginning.
So that's what an H-like wave
function is, just one electron,
just three variables;
Ï ,
Î¸,
Ï† are the convenient
ones.
Okay, but now we want to see
how we scale it as we change the
nuclear charge.
We already started talking
about that last time when we
talked about Ï ,
but we're going to talk about
size,
also about electron density,
and also about energy and how
the energies of these
one-electron atoms change as you
change the nuclear charge.
Okay, this is what we talked
about last time,
that if you make the table up,
the formulas,
in Ï ,
instead of in r,
then you could use it for any
hydrogen-like atom,
because the distance scale gets
multiplied by the nuclear
charge;
that is to say,
if you have a given
Ï  --
that's a given size of the
function we're talking about --
a given Ï ,
then you have that value at
shorter r,
if you have a higher Z;
a tradeoff between Z and
r.
If you double Z,
you get the same value at half
the r.
Does that make sense,
that as you get Z
bigger, the distances get
smaller?
Does that make sense?
Why?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: Because the
nucleus pulls the electron in
more.
And notice that it's linear,
right?
If you double the nuclear
charge, you shrink by a factor
of two, in the distance.
Okay?
So increasing Z shrinks
the wave function,
makes r smaller for the
same Ï ;
that is, the same height of the
wave function,
or the same position in the
shape of the wave function,
because you have to renormalize
if you shrink the wave function.
Okay, so let's compare
hydrogen, carbon^(+6),
and potassium^(+19).
Right?
So the distance scale will go
1,1/6th, 1/19th.
So this is what it looks like.
If a hydrogen atom is that big,
this is how big the carbon
one-electron atom is,
and that's how big the
potassium one-electron is,
1/19th as the linear distance
that's in hydrogen.
Now, how much does the electron
density change?
I think that's the next thing;
yeah, scaling electron density
with Z.
You can see that just from what
we just talked about.
If you shrink the distance by a
factor of two,
how much do you change the
density?
Factor of two,
does the density get twice as
high if you make the distance
half as long?
Ryan?
Student:  2^(3).
Prof: It's got to be
2^(3), because you shrink it
this way and this way and also
this way.
So it goes up with
Z^(3),
the density.
That means if you have a
hydrogen atom,
the electrons are every
which-a-way,
all over, but if you have even
a carbon atom,
six times the nuclear charge
for the same 1s orbital,
the density is 6^(3) as big.
What's 6^(3)?
Thirty-six -- ~fourty five --
over 200, right?
So you have 200 times the
electron density for the
1s electron in carbon,
compared to the 1s
electron in hydrogen.
Where does that crop up in
experiment --
that you have so much higher
electron density for carbon than
you do for hydrogen --
and other things are even more
so,
like potassium -- where does it
crop up?
Yeah?
Student:  The contour
plots.
Prof: Of what?
Student:  Of the
molecules, the bond lengths.
Prof: What experiment?
Student:  I forget.
Prof: Close.
What?
Student:  I forget.
Prof: You can do it by
calculation and you'd see much
higher density.
That's what we're talking about
is theory, but where do you see
it experimentally?
Lucas?
Student:  Refraction
difference diagrams.
Prof: Not to do --
well you can do it in the
difference,
but if you look at the total
electron density you don't see
hydrogens,
unless you look -- work --
really hard,
because the density of
electrons, which is what you're
seeing,
is so much higher for other
atoms.
Okay, so the normalization has
to be one.
So if you shrink it,
and that's where that comes in.
We talked about that
Z/a_o to the
3/2 that gets squared before,
and so that the
Î¨^(2) is proportional
to Z^(3),
and the density of the
1s electron,
as you go across these atoms,
goes from one to 216 to 7000;
potassium is 7000 times higher.
Remember where we saw that in
X-ray, what a very dark atom
that was.
Okay, so it helps X-rays find
heavier atoms more easily.
Now how about the kinetic
energy?
Right?
So Î¨ is a function
of r, some kind of
function of r,
but it includes a Z;
Z times r,
because Ï  is
Z times r.
So now, how does that influence
the derivative,
right?
If you have a function of
Zr, the derivative of it
is Z times the function of Z,
by the derivative of -- oh
what's it?;
blah-blah.
I got that wrong,
or do I have it right?
Student:  That's right.
Prof: That's right,
yeah I got it right.
Okay, now about how about the
second derivative?
Student:  Z^(2).
Prof: It's going to have
a Z^(2 )in it,
right?
So the curvature is going to be
Z^(2 )times what the
curvature was before,
but the value of the wave
function is the same at some --
the corresponding Ï .
So what's going to happen to
the kinetic energy?
If you have a bigger nuclear
charge, what's going to happen
to the kinetic energy at any
point, at a corresponding point?
Right?
It's going to be proportional
to Z^(2),
the curvature divided by the
value of the wave function.
Right?
So the kinetic energy is going
to really zoom up for a
hydrogen-like atom,
when you get a heavier atom.
Right?
So let's summarize what we did
so far.
So distance will shrink
according to Z,
electron density will go up
according to Z^(3),
and the kinetic energy will go
with Z^(2).
Okay?
Now how about the potential
energy, how will it change as we
change the nuclear charge?
Well if we change the nuclear
charge;
Coulomb's law includes the
nuclear charge,
right?
So at the same distance you'll
have Z times whatever it
was for hydrogen,
much higher,
or indeed lower potential
energy,
more negative,
further from zero.
Okay, but at a fixed-- that's--
so at a fixed distance the
potential energy will be
proportional to Z;
but the distance shrinks, right?
So if you look at corresponding
positions in the wave function,
or you look at the average
potential energy,
it's going to go-- it's going
to also be,
take into account that the
distance gets smaller,
r gets smaller,
because the thing got shrunken
by a factor of Z.
So what happens to the average
potential energy?
How does it it scale with
Z?
Maria, you got an idea?
At a given distance,
the energy, according to
Coulomb's law,
will be multiplied by Z,
because you've got a bigger
nuclear charge,
but every distance gets shrunk
by a factor of Z.
Right?
So if you average everything,
what are you going to get?
There are two factors of
Z that are increasing (or
decreasing, making more
favorable) the energy,
the potential energy.
Got that?
Two factors.
So what's it going to be?
Student:  Z^(2).
Prof: Z^(2),
right?
So the potential energy--what
did the kinetic energy go with?
Remember how the kinetic energy
scaled?
Student:  Z^(2).
Prof: Z^(2).
How does the potential energy
scale?
Student:  Z^(2).
Prof: How about the
average potential energy,
if I double the nuclear charge?
How much lower is the --
obviously if I increase the
charge,
the average energy of the
electrons is going to get lower,
but for two reasons,
because the nuclear charge is
bigger,
and because the electron is
twice as close.
Okay?
So how does it scale,
the potential energy average?
Z^(2).
So the kinetic energy scales
with Z^(2),
the potential energy scales
with Z^(2).
How about the total energy?
This is a hard one.
Student:  Z^(2).
Prof:  Z^(2),
right?
Okay, so the potential energy
goes as Z^(2),
and the total energy,
here's a big surprise,
it goes with Z^(2) too.
It also happens to be
1/(n^(2)).
Right?
So the energy gets -- yeah,
so as you go up in n,
you get less stable,
right?
Now R turns out to be
about 300 kilocalories/mole,
if you want to really get what
the energies are.
And here is a plot of the
energies.
Here's the 1s,
2s or 2p,
3s or 3p or
3d, 4s,
p, d,
f and so on,
right?
But the distance from zero,
the amount of stabilization,
is proportional to
1/(n^(2));
and we saw the same thing if we
did-- in the one-dimensional
Coulomb case,
the energy was also
1/(n^(2)).
Okay.
Notice it's independent of
l and m;
3s is the same as
3p is the same as
3d.
Does that square with what you
have learned before?
Student:  No.
Prof: What did you learn
before?
Lexy, did you learn anything
about that before,
about the energies of
3s, 3p,
3d?
No.
Anybody?
Shai?
Student:  s,
p, d.
Prof: Yes,
s is lower than p
is lower than d.
Now how can both these things
be true, that you heard
something that was true,
and I'm telling you they're all
the same?
Student:  There are more
electrons.
Prof: Ah-ha!
What you heard about was real
atoms, things that have many
electrons.
I'm telling you about if the
atom has only one electron,
then s and p and
d are the same.
Okay?
But it'll be different when you
have many electrons,
and we'll see why shortly.
Okay, because this is
one-electron atoms.
Okay, so we've -- this just
summarizes --
the size goes with 1/Z,
the electron density is
proportional to Z^(3),
and the energy goes with
Z^(2),
whether you're talking
potential, kinetic or total
energy.
Okay, and it's also
1/n^(2).
And the size happens to be
n/Z as well.
Okay, now here's a really
pretty one, and to do this,
to see this right,
you want to see the real thing.
So notice that this is a
2p orbital;
n, l,
m are 2,1,1.
Everybody see that?
I want to show you the real
program that does that.
<<Technical adjustments
to show 3d orbital in
Atom-in-a-Box
program>>
Okay, now what I want for the
display -- this display is just
as if electrons were all white,
okay?
But we want to color them
according to the color of the --
<<Technical Adjustments of
Atom-in-a-Box
format>>
-- we want to color them with
the phase, plus,
minus.
That's 3d.
The phase keeps changing.
That has to do with time
dependence, which we're not
talking about.
Okay?
Now, that's a 3d orbital.
We want to have -- what did we
have before?
We had 2p, right?
So I'll make this instead of a
three, a two.
So there's a 2p orbital,
a particular 2p orbital,
2,1,0.
Which one is that?
Notice you have a coordinate
system next door there,
and I can rotate this thing,
I can grab it and rotate it;
the coordinate system rotates.
See that?
Student: Cool!
Prof: So I can look at
it end-on if I want to,
or look at it from the side.
Which p orbital is that?
Students:
2p_z.
Prof: How do you know?
Prof: Points along the
z axis.
Okay?
Now, let's look at another
2p orbital,
because we can make m
one instead of zero.
So the 2,1,0 is
2p_z.
Now what's 2,1,1?
Let me look at it this way.
That's time-dependence,
right, and that's weird.
And physicists love this sort
of thing, because they deal with
atoms in isolation,
and atoms in isolation have
angular momentum,
things going around.
But atoms, when they're in
molecules,
when they're with other atoms,
or in other things that distort
it,
like in an electric field,
they don't behave that way.
So chemists use a different way
of doing it, right?
It's not that physicists are
right and chemists are wrong,
or that chemists are right and
physicists are wrong,
it's if you're dealing with
isolated atoms,
you use one thing;
if you're dealing with atoms
interacting with other atoms you
should use something else.
And the way you do this,
dealing with something else --
I'll show you here.
You do what's called
superposition;
that is, you add two functions
in order to get a new function,
and the two functions I'm going
to add,
when I click
"Superposition"
here,
are 2,1,1, and the other one
I'm going to use is 2,1,-1.
And now what's that?
Students:
2p_y.
Prof: That's the
2p_y orbital.
Okay, does everybody see what I
did?
So I can combine two of the
physicist's orbitals to get the
chemist's 2p_y
orbital.
Dean Dauger,
who wrote this,
is a physicist,
so he writes physicist
programs, right?
But we can trick it to be
chemistry by adding two of his
together, or by subtracting
them;
and when you subtract them you
have to put an i in --
imaginary.
So I'm not going to do it right
now.
You can do it yourself.
You can see down here,
you can do the phase and so on;
the phase of p makes it
imaginary.
I won't do that now.
We'll go back to the PowerPoint.
<<Technical Adjustment to
change program>>
So superposition of that kind,
when you add two functions
together to get a new function,
for whatever purpose,
is a kind of what's called
hybridization.
Now there are other kinds of --
have you heard about hybrid
orbitals?
Right.
What that is is adding two
orbitals together to get a new
orbital.
And let's look about when that
would be.
As we said, this is the
physicist's 2p,
m=1, with orbital
angular momentum,
and it has complex numbers
involved.
And the chemist's 2p is
that sum.
Okay.
Now multiplying and adding wave
functions.
We've already seen a case where
you multiply functions.
Do you remember where we've
seen things be multiplied?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: Alison,
do you remember?
No.
Student:  You multiplied
the wave functions.
Prof: Multiplied which
wave functions?
Let me tell you one place we
already multiplied was squaring
a wave function is a kind of
multiplication to get
probability.
But I want a different one.
Student:  When we,
for different variables --
Prof: Ah,
for separating the variables,
r, Î¸ and
Ï†;
we had an R function,
a Î˜ function,
a Î¦ function,
and we multiplied these pieces
together to get the total wave
function for the electron,
the three-dimensional wave
function.
So that's one place you
multiply, to get a one-electron
wave function,
which is -- we call an orbital.
An orbital is a one-electron
wave function;
that's what an orbital is.
Now, you can add orbitals to
create a hybrid orbital;
that's what we just did,
we took two physicist's
orbitals, added them together,
and got a new orbital.
Okay?
2p_y +
2p_z is a
hybrid orbital.
An orbital is a one-electron
wave function.
What's it a function of?
What variables do you put in,
in order to get a value out?
How many variables?
Sophie?
Student:  Three.
Prof: Three.
What are they?
Student:  Those.
Prof: The position of
that electron,
the one electron.
If it's a one-electron orbital,
you can write the orbital as
many pieces -- here are two
pieces, right?
But it still is a function of
just the position of one
electron;
it's not a function of six,
or eighteen,
or whatever number of
variables, it's just a function
of --
it's an orbital,
a one-electron function,
so it's a position of one
electron that you plug in.
Now, you can change orientation
of orbitals by hybridization.
Let's look at that.
So here's the 2p_z
orbital.
I've rotated the coordinate
system so z is
horizontal.
Okay?
And here's the 2py_
orbital,
which we already made by adding
two physicist's orbitals
together.
Okay?
Now what happens -- and notice
the 2p_y ,
surprise, is pointed along the
y axis,
2p_z was
pointed along the z axis.
What if I add the two together?
What if I add 2p_z
and 2p_y?
Now let's go back and look at
2p_z a second.
Notice it's red on the left,
blue on the right;
say positive numbers on the
left, negative numbers on the
right -- everybody with me?
-- because it assigns numbers
to different points in space,
positive numbers on the left,
negative on the right,
let's say.
Now this one assigns positive
numbers on the top,
negative numbers on the bottom.
Suppose I add together,
what am I going to get?
Andrew?
Student:  You get
diagonal.
Prof: Ah,
they should reinforce in the
top left where they're both
positive,
and in the bottom right where
they're both negative,
but in the bottom left and the
top right they should cancel.
Okay?
So if we add them together to
make a weighted sum -- we don't
have to add them 50:50,
but we'll start by adding
50:50.
Okay?
So if we add them,
a 50:50 mixture will give that,
just what you said.
Okay, so we changed the
orientation of the p
orbital by adding two.
Okay, now suppose we didn't use
50%, suppose we used another
mixture, suppose we used 75%,
right?
Or there's 50%, or 25%.
Okay?
So you can get any orientation
you want by mixing -- within
that plane, within the yz
plane, by adjusting the ratio.
Okay, there's
2p_y.
Now, what would happen with a
2s orbital if you put it
in an electric field?
You're changing the rules,
you're changing the potential,
because now the electron has --
doesn't just --
its energy doesn't depend just
on its distance from the
nucleus,
it also depends on where it is
in the field.
So we're changing the
definition of the potential
energy.
So it's a different quantum
mechanical problem.
But I don't want you to think
about quantum mechanics,
I just want you to think about
what would happen if you put an
electric field on.
What do you think?
Student:  It shouldn't
--
Prof: Would it move the
atom?
Student:  Yes.
Prof: No,
because the atom is neutral,
overall.
We'll do a hydrogen atom here.
The atom's neutral,
so it won't move.
But what will happen?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: The electrons will
move one way and the nucleus
will move the other,
and if you've preserved the
center of mass,
then the nucleus will hardly
move at all,
and the electrons will do most
of the moving.
Okay.
So you can change the shape by
hybridization.
We can get something that will
work in an electric field,
describe an atom in an electric
field, by mixing the ones
without electric field.
Now let's look how we do that.
We make an sp^(n) hybrid
orbital.
Have you ever seen that?;
n is a number.
Can you give me an example?
two, sp^(2) or?
Student:  sp^(3).
Prof: sp^(3) or
sp, where n is
one, right?
Or sp^(0).
Have you ever seen that?
Student:  No.
Prof: sp^(0) is
just s.
This is how much p there
is in it, after you square it.
That is, it's a weighted sum,
this thing you're using.
You have different values of
a and b,
and it's weighted such that --
so when you square it,
you get a^(2),
a fraction of 2s
squared;
that's the distribution
2s would have;
b^(2) of the way
p_y would be
when squared.
But you also get a cross-term,
2ab times 2s
times 2p.
Okay, now so n,
the number you put in to talk
about sp^(2),
sp^(3) and so on,
is the square of
b^(2)/a^(2).
So if you have an sp
hybrid,
it means equal parts of
s and p,
and if you have sp^(3) ,
it means three times as much
p as s,
after squaring.
Okay, so it's what fraction you
have of something that looks
like 2s squared and
2p squared;^( )and then
there's also that part.
Okay, so now let's just look at
some examples here.
Suppose n is zero;
then you have just pure
s.
Okay?
Now suppose you put an electric
field that wants to shift the
electrons.
It would push a positive charge
to the right but it will push
electrons to the left.
Okay, so let's -- here we went
to 0.02, just a tiny amount of
p.
But see how it -- here's back
to s, and there's
sp^(0.02).
It shifted the electrons to the
left.
What if I go to a higher value?
0.4 0.04,0.06,0.09,0
.11,0.18,0.25,0.33.
So what I'm doing is turning up
a dial to make the electron --
electric field stronger -- and
the electron is shifting,
by changing the hybridization.
Okay, 0.5,1.
There's an sp hybrid.
Now what'll happen if I keep on
going, make it sp^(2),
for example.
What do you think will happen?
Guess.
Student:  It'll get more
and more to the right.
Prof: It'll keep going
to the right.
Wrong!
Watch this.
That's the maximum extension is
sp.
That's the most you can extend.
Now watch what happens if I
make it bigger;
sp^(2),
sp^(3),
sp^(4),
sp^(9),
sp^(24),
pure p.
Right?
Because both pure s and
pure p are symmetrical.
The 50:50 mixture is the one
that shifts the most to the
left.
Okay, now we're going to close
here with trying to go beyond
what we've already seen.
What we've seen is one-electron
atoms, hydrogen-like atoms.
So we find that we can multiply
pieces,
R, Î˜,
Î¦,
to create this one-electron
wave function,
the orbital,
and we can furthermore add
these things to make hybrids
that shift things around in
useful ways.
We can add orbitals to make an
sp hybrid,
for example,
as what would happen in an
electric field.
But it's still an orbital,
so it allows adjusting to new
situations --
for example,
an electric field -- while
preserving the virtues of real
solutions of the nuclear
potential,
because you never put on a
field as strong as the field
felt by the electron near a
nucleus.
Adding the external field by
turning up your dial is just a
small change.
So you want things to look
pretty much like what they
looked originally,
with the nucleus,
just a little change,
and you can do that by
hybridization.
Okay, the big deal is the
nuclear potential at small
distances.
Now, let's try to go to a
two-electron wave function.
Okay?
So what's it a function of?
What's a two-electron wave
function going to be a function
of, how many variables?
Students:  Six.
Prof: Right, six, right?
x,y,z for
one electron,
and x,y,z
for the other electron,
or r,
Î¸,
Ï† of electron one,
and r,
Î¸,
Ï† of electron two,
and they're on the same
nucleus, so you measure the
distances from the same point,
but they're two different
distances,
one to electron one,
another to electron two.
They could be the same,
but they don't need to be,
they could be different.
Okay?
Now wouldn't it be neat --
that's the question mark -- if
we could get that by multiplying
two one-electron wave functions?
Because we have one-electron
wave functions cold;
we look in the table and we've
got the exact thing.
If we could take two of those
and multiply them together,
so orbital A for electron one
times orbital B for electron two
--
remember, what these things are
is just numbers.
If you put in some value of
position of electron one and
some value of position of
electron two,
this first thing will give you
a number,
the second thing will give you
a number.
If you could multiply those two
numbers together and get the
number for the total wave
function,
that would be really great,
because then you'd know how to
do it.
The question is,
can you do that?
Remember, an orbital is a
one-electron wave function.
So can we multiply orbitals in
order to get a many-electron
wave function?
If we could -- and then,
of course, we would square it
to get probability density.
Now it would be a different
probability.
In the first case it was
probability of electron one
being here.
Now it's the joint probability
of electron one is here,
and electron two at the same
time is here;
that's the probability when you
have six variables.
Okay?
Wouldn't that be great?
It's just paradise, right?
Because if we had many
electrons we could just multiply
all those orbitals together,
a certain orbital for electron
one,
another orbital for electron
two, another one for electron
three.
We know how to write those;
multiply them together,
we get the thing.
We find the total energy is
whatever energy electron one
had, plus whatever energy
electron two had.
That's great.
We find the total electron
density.
We know how to find the
electron density of each
individual electron.
So the total electron density
should be just the sum of those.
So if we were interested in the
total electron density at this
particular point,
we'd see what the electron
density of electron one is at
that point,
and what the electron density
of electron two is at that
point,
and we'd add them together and
that would give the total
electron density,
at that point.
So the total electron density
is a function of x,
y, z.
It's whatever this is,
evaluated at x,
y, z,
plus whatever this,
plus all the others.
Absolutely wonderful. Right?
And then you could write things.
So the whole is the sum of the
parts.
Right?
And you could write things like
this at the top,
that Neon has the
configuration:
two electrons in 1s,
two electrons in 2s,
two electrons in
2p_x,
2p_y.
Right?
Things like that.
You've seen things like that.
So those are the orbitals in
which electrons are,
to describe the neon atom.
Right?
Now, this is a problem in joint
probability.
So it's like tossing two coins
to try to get to two heads.
So I don't know if I can do
these at the same time,
but I have two quarters here.
Need your back of your hand.
Okay, so I got tails.
What did you get?
Student:  Heads.
Prof: How often?
Student:  Half the time.
Prof: Half the time.
Actually if I get tails and you
get heads, that's a quarter of
the time.
Student:  Yes,
that's a quarter of the time.
Prof: But a quarter of
the time you'll get tails and
I'll get heads.
So heads/tails is half the time.
How about heads/heads,
how often?
Student:  Heads/heads.
Still a quarter.
Prof: A quarter of the
time.
Now I'll bet you,
I'll bet you that I can get
head/head half the time,
actually doing the experiment.
Student:  Yes.
Prof: You want to take
the bet?
I would advise against it.
>
Prof: Okay,
here's what I'm going to do.
<<Professor McBride tapes
the quarters together>>
Prof: Two tails, I lose.
>
Prof: Whoops.
Prof: Two tails,
I lost again.
But I think you can see that if
I do it a lot of times I'm going
to win half the time.
Why?
Why was the rule wrong?
Prof: Because they
weren't independent,
right?
If they're independent,
the probability of both A and
B,
that is, the probability that A
will be here and at the same
time B will be here,
is the product of the
probabilities;
but if you do this,
that's not true anymore.
Right?
So if you have a two-electron
wave function,
you square it to get the joint
probability,
that electron one will be here
and electron two will be here at
the same time.
So is that valid,
to multiply -- here I'm
multiplying the individual
probabilities that electron A is
at a certain position,
electron B is at another
position.
Do I get the joint probability
that way?
Well under what conditions do I
get the joint probability that
way?
Students:
If they're independent.
Prof: If they're
independent.
Now, here's the big question.
Are they independent?
Students:  No.
Prof: Why not?
Prof: Because of
Coulomb's law,
they repel one another.
There's no way they can be
independent, they repel one
another.
So orbitals,
one-electron wave functions,
to express many-electron wave
functions, cannot be right.
Orbitals are a fiction,
except for one-electron
problems.
Right?
hydrogen-like atoms fine;
we've got hydrogen atoms cold.
But if you got more than one
electron, orbitals won't work.
But still we're going to use
them.
>
Prof: Right?
And that's what you're going to
find out after the exam.
Okay, good luck on -- so that
doesn't work -- good luck on the
exam.